Terry would you do the honors you almost
killed me
I'm not going out and still making
accident Terry's gonna die saving the
president okay never gonna die leave it
to the NYPD to screw up being hostages I
thought cops loved to sit around on
their fat asses all day and do nothing
that's it
[Music]
no waiting just toasting I want you to
toast I want any toast
give me some tokens I'll be right there
she makes all of us feel things oh sorry
hmm can I be honest
precincts not the same without you the
vultures the worst my mango yogurt as
you already mentioned the yogurt cuz
it's important this screw has three
points I didn't hear that did you I'm
still hearing it the keys are locked
inside the car and that's what you get
for lying about free strudel Karma's a
[ __ ]
what are you doing whatever it takes to
make Amy happy you told me to do this
now let's get these gift bags to the
menu because I care Oh feels so good oh
you're really stepping on my moment here
Terry let's go if it helps I brought you
some soothing ginger tea will we pair
the place where my nose came off my
skull I don't know but it's supposed to
have healing vapors so try and hailing
it thank you
oh you got I know you got it I want my
money
I took down Gina linetti I did the
impossible
teri is back Oh Chuck time for up what
so what should I do
maybe don't jump to conclusions no
interrogate him follow the plan
Rosa follow the plan well Terry's
trapped in the break room forever only
thing we can do now is move on with our
lives is what Terry would have wanted
god bless us everyone are you talking
about oil is fully nude in the footage
why we're back on the day shift come on
you